how's it going reject nation Greg Alba
here neck cellent there from double
toast it is here excellent zmax double
toast calm okay yeah I need a promote
you properly third time's a while I
thought your name was Doug to Richard do
it again Vmax illan sammy from double
toast calm is here he's visiting LA just
to be on the channel I'm not from here I
don't care doesn't matter
here here the people flying back one of
the segments we like to do on this
channel that's very recent it's called
trailers revisited and what we do here
is we look at trailers for movies we've
already seen and we like to determine
how accurate was the movie portrayed to
get the tone properly communicated is to
spoil anything because trailers are a
big part of our viewing area
and yeah the what we're doing today is
especially important to trailer analyses
movies we can use so Ironman one this is
one of the most requested trailers
revisited that's probably the most
requested Rosa visit we've ever done so
I thought this would be fun and then
looking back on it I don't think I ever
saw an Iron Man for a serious I want to
opening night because someone asked me
to come with them and so I did and then
I ended up loving it but I remembered
watching it going I have no idea what
about I was a Saturday morning cartoon
yeah they had a night and I have toys I
love I've seen posters but I really
could not recall a tree ignorant and
know who Robert Downey jr. was at the
time it sounds like this guy seems cool
what I did if he ever stumbles across it
which he definitely will yes send it
that's what he does he looks himself I
keep sending this to him
anyway let's check it out Iron Man
trailer number one I have no idea like
how this all go oh I know that pace were
patients about oh yeah yeah I remember
now
lastly the green so there were a fair
amount his hair is magnificent oh yeah
Terrence Howard Billy Zane
[Music]
I really go through like the first 40
minutes of this movie huh
I definitely did not see this trailer I
think I saw a moment that wasn't in the
movie oh yeah whoa spoilers
[Music]
you're just showing the movie it's kind
of a lot of the movie
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's face it this is not the worst
thing you've got me doing the effects of
oh yeah walk away
[Music]
yeah that that's the whole movie I don't
I definitely did not watch this trailer
because when I saw this in the theaters
all this was a surprise okay nowadays I
see a trailer and then I watch a movie
I'm like why not I was gonna play I saw
the trailer yes I remember watching that
movie and like wow this is all shocking
this is the opening scene right here the
only difference is you know we've got
some basil old member that man the cool
thing about Iron Man that movies it's
all the details right yeah you know like
that's where you feel the heart of the
movie like the heart of it is not really
communicated here what's communicated
here is the other tones of the film
regret too because yeah honestly he's
building all these warp more machines
I'm sorry all these tools of war and
he's like I made a billion dollars off
of this and now I'm sorry too bad about
it because now I could see the
repercussions from this exactly exactly
so they're doing what a trailer arguably
should do which is show you the
characters goal where they're from why
they're doing it so we could get on
board for it right that's cool there's
like things that are not really
capitalized on that they don't really
give away like the whole sequence with
the cave was that character's name
yinsen yes yeah yeah
remember Korea the daughter saying that
right another thing to note I mean we
were still in the midst of like the Iraq
war and aftermath of those wars and this
is very reflective of those times where
it's like yeah we're in the Middle East
doing all sorts of bad stuff and this is
how our arms are being dealt and this
movie kind of actually places that and
it hints at those type of themes that
were happening in real life and this
would consider great at the time and
then I have Black Panther which is
hitting on themes that are happening at
the same time it's like a little bit
daddy the best Marvel movie seem to be
the ones that are able to capture those
little yeah exact time even though this
is 10 years old we know that oh yeah I
remember these types of things and
they're portraying these types of
conflicts as still relevant to kind of
the historical context even within the
MCU itself well that's what makes them
feel truly heroic I think his hair is so
let's break this down alright it starts
off oh my god oh my god yes and then
yeah it shows the Jericho they get
attacked iron man gets kidnapped forced
to build something they show that he
builds prototype Iron Man suit breaks
out visits America I have something I'm
working on starts building an Iron Man I
mean if you know the comics then yeah
it's a bad guy but if you don't like
when I was watching the movie yeah I'm
like yeah Jeff Fred just kind of plays
it like he's a bad guy but I did know
for sure yes so what I'm watching the
movie it comes as a plot reveal yeah so
to reveal that in the trailer what a big
wanna no idea that yeah this guy maybe
morally ambiguous ya know this is the
man in the bed he's working with the
terrorists that's kidnap Tony Stark
let's get the hot rod in there Pepper
Potts finds out he's Iron Man and then
eventually Obadiah Stane builds his own
Iron Man suit the Iron Monger and then
they fight every day goes to the Middle
East and shoot some guys on a tank cap
and it's like okay the wolf is there
yeah it serves a plot point they give
you all the beats from beginning to end
but the cool thing is about Iron Man
it's all the details like the whole
chemistry between him and Pepper Potts
the chemistry between him and Rhodey
I mean his
charisma in general I mean Tony Stark
everyone fell in love with him after
that movie and I remember when he goes
back to Afghanistan and you know [ __ ]
up all those terrorists that was really
felt - when he's just sitting at the TV
looking at the crime he's like screw
this I'm going over there yeah I really
felt that there because this trailer
makes it all look like this abuse I'm
like that's cool here we go
but then when you watch the movie
there's a lot more heart to the film
right a lot more emotional state
complexity but this also was the
beginning of the duplicate bed of Marvel
villains you know yeah oh yeah we're
gonna have an Iron Man they're evil I
have a sorcerer and then we're gonna
have an evil sorcerer yeah what are the
duplicate bad guys are there in the
Marvin what's cool about this trailer is
they do show that he's gonna have a
press conference because people are
starting to suspect he's Iron Man right
what's so neat though is they didn't
give away the biggest surprise which is
the last line of the movie yeah that
would just kill the trees like little
details in terms of the major plot
points are all revealed here there's
some tonal stuff that's kind of missing
literally the only plot points that are
not given away the big ones are I am
Iron Man and Nick Fury shows up at the
end yeah now we're here Martin Thomas
from double toast calm website I'm from
he what was that is that again Sammy
I said Martin Thomas from double toast
comm double toasted double toasted
dot-com toasted Martin Thomas doubled
terms he said that last part came out
was that we're doing the Avengers
initiative he said there will never be
an Avengers movie this got the hype
going and this is what's made over a
hundred million dollars opening weekend
and it deserves it because it's a great
movie great movie yeah all right well
that was fun yeah
genuinely surprised by how much is rude
I think what your introduction though
you kind of have to give away a lot yeah
and this is a 10 years ago so it makes
sense alright guys well thanks for
watching what other
what other trailers do you recommend
that are worth revisiting at this point
in our lives leave it in the comment
boxes below guys you can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bell so subscribe buttons
can mean something and also check us out
on patreon full-length TV show reactions
weekly Q&A s
but more importantly both Sami veeam
excellence on Instagram and Twitter and
check out Sami had a bunch of other
people from the crew double toasted calm
yes go subscribe we have live streams
just about every night and we also have
a YouTube channel and SoundCloud so just
search us you'll find us